did you guys know that your videos
discussing Andrew Tate were gonna blow
up the way that they did so with the
initial videos I kind of made those
intentionally to go viral with the
entertain ones I was like Andrew Tate is
the most trending thing and Mom reacts
as like a cheat code going viral so I
kind of just put those two together it
was a business decision on his part yeah
it was definitely calculated and then
I'd use like specific algorithm stuff I
know behind the scenes marketed on Tick
Tock so it definitely blew up more than
I thought but yeah I didn't think that I
didn't think that me being as part of
the channel would really be as big of a
thing as it is and uh it's turning into
something that's really fun for us and a
really fun way for us to spend time
together and these are the conversations
we have anyway so for you know him to be
able to use it in business it must be
able to have a good time is awesome but
yeah it's kind of it this is not a path
I I thought I was going to be on if you
would have told me I was going to be on
this path earlier this year I would no
making YouTube videos yeah I know it is
funny to think about that's a cool path
I mean you're on it too and you you guys
are doing really well and you know did
you expect this yourselves it's funny
because if I mentioned the beginning we
started this Channel with the sole
purpose of if we can just help one
person then that's enough for us so we I
mean we had our hopes but me personally
I never expected to see like a hundred
thousand which we're about to hit 100
you know I was we just had the goal of
we want to help people we want to guide
people to Islam we want to speak the
truth and dispel any misconceptions that
are out there I think it's a really cool
Mission you know as a as a Christian and
you've seen some of our videos where
I've been talking about how my level of
Christianity has stepped up over the
past year or so and you know it was like
in and out my whole life but I've you
know come to it in a whole different way
this year and so one of the things I
understand that my job as a disciple is
to be a fisher of men that's how it was
put to you know Jesus's disciples in in
the in the Bible and you're doing that
and you're you know not fishing for
Jesus of course but I really really
think that whether I catch some fish or
you catch some fish I think we're making
we can make the world a better place by
bringing people closer to God either way
is going to be better so it's very cool
that that's your whole point I love it
absolutely absolutely and that doesn't
mean a lot and you know it's actually
it's funny because from our perspective
we would say that we are actually also
fulfilling the you know fishing for
Jesus kind of mission because we believe
that Jesus called people to worship one
God alone and to enjoin good and forbid
evil and I don't know maybe it's a
little early to pull this out the
brothers know what I'm about to pull out
but I have this uh this book here it's
called the five gospels and um long
story short they put in Gray letters
things Jesus probably didn't say black
letters things he didn't say and then
you see like the pink down here these
are things Jesus probably did say and
when I was going through it I found a
lot of Jesus's most beautiful messages
are the ones that the scholars who put
this together agree he probably said
this like he almost definitely said this
you know for example love thy enemies
isn't like red bold letters so messages
like that are the ones that Muslims
resonate with very very kindly and it's
kind of that understanding of Jesus that
we want to portray to the world but for
Elena for you I know that you mentioned
recently you kind of came back to it and
sunny I know that you mentioned that
you're interested in Islam because you
know recently educate accepted Islam and
that kind of gazed your interest so how
are you both with you know Christianity
Islam and spirituality I've never like
I've grown up Christian but I've never
been too big into church myself like
I've just never really resonated with it
you know and my my view on Islam has
always been very like Americanized if
you know what I mean like I'm not
surrounded by Muslims growing up you
know I could only name like a couple
handful that I went to school with or
something like that so I never really
knew about the religion like even for
the longest time when I would think
about it it's like in my mind I wouldn't
have ever thought Jesus would be the
most mentioned Prophet inside of the
Quran like I I think it's like a
completely different religion like if I
think of like Hinduism and it has like
elephant like I have no idea what's what
was really going on inside you know what
I mean and seeing you know how many
similarities there are inside the
religions especially with like core
beliefs has definitely changed my mind
to it a ton over the last few months you
know absolutely I I agree so yeah again
we were we're taught everything we need
to know about Islam through
um the media with a political slant that
talks taught you know we learned about
Islam through learning about terrorist
political organizations who happen to
also be Muslim right and but and it all
just becomes one thing in the news you
know and one of our big things is in all
of our videos is we tell everybody don't
believe what you see in the news look
deeper look deeper go ask questions and
get more opinions do your own research
and you know so for us it you know we're
putting our money where our mouth is by
really researching Islam and and I and
I'm glad that we're doing that and for
me this this you know my Christian path
without getting into it because it's
been a long life you know all of it I
don't want to bore you to death but God
was always just on a throne in the sky
and very distant and that for is what
Catholicism did for me and you know I've
I've taken part more in um actual Bible
study and being more into the Baptist
sect of Christianity which is you know
really more biblical teachings and
Mission work and I'm not doing any
Mission work yet but like that's what
they do they really reach out into the
community so I have now a totally
different relationship with God and with
Jesus and it's so much more awesome and
real for me so he hasn't had that
experience yet you know we're just I'm
just bringing him into it because he was
raised Catholic he was raised with God
on the throne scary out there not really
in your heart and where Islam comes in
for me is I'm particularly fascinated
with the study of it now and seeing the
commonalities that's where I'm at right
now because I'm digging deeper and
deeper into the Old and New Testament
and really starting to learn for the
first time in my life in a way that's
meaningful and I'm you know what I
learned from all these videos and all
these conversations is where the Common
Ground we have and I think that that's
so awesome that to me is like so
beautiful that we have so much common
ground and I think that's a message that
we need to spread so absolutely
absolutely there's a question that just
comes straight to my mind if you guys
don't mind me asking her but did you
know before at least let's say before
you started you know looking into Islam
a little bit more that it was also an
abrahamic faith nope
I didn't know no I don't even have a
long answer on that one just no
yeah I mean there's a lot I don't know
there's still a ton I don't I mean I
I've only scratched the surface on
Christianity I went to 12 years of
Catholic school and I feel like a new
Christian so so I'm learning both of
these uh both of these religions in
parallel it is how it feels more I know
more about Christianity just because I
did pick up something in all those years
but in in a really deeper biblical
scholarly way this is a whole new world
for me so yeah just learning that yeah
so you said that you grew up learning
Catholicism correct yes so it's actually
amazing that you're saying what you're
saying that you're doing what you're
doing you know may God bless you because
you you truly seem sincere and you know
which saying you're still in everything
and I'm sure there's there's way more to
your story because you only
as much but in Islam like we're actually
told to look for the answers to read for
ourselves and we're told to not not just
blindly follow what those before us are
following so like our parents our family
in general we're told to actually just
like look for the answers you saw
because if you're sincere uh God will
show you everything yeah so I think I
think it's it's real beautiful that
y'all are on this path all right make
sure you guys like subscribe and if
you're interested in learning how to
dominate social media and make money
online I'm having a crazy sale with my
Online Academy where I teach you all my
strategies how I've hit over a hundred
thousand Subs in four months how I've
generated five million dollars using
organic marketing so DM me bank if you
guys want to learn more about that
and
[Music]
[Music]